[Music]
imagine imagine a world that we
currently live in where you can be fined
for farting next to an office yeah I
like it intentionally why someone has
IBS and they can't control it Joe how do
you feel like that I feel like it's my
right to fart this man in Vienna in
Austria so he apparently he rose
slightly from the park man laughs do you
have to look at the officers I wonder if
I went to the same Park as him and
intentionally released a massive how do
we know that in the immediate vicinity
of the officers say so they find the man
by 160 dollars so I've hundred euros but
for more intentionally farting but
that's not a law it's not illegal to do
that so what was it filed under was
distress like just disrespect to SOLAS
it wasn't saying that he violated that
they violated public decency by loudly
blowing a bowel in front of police
officers and for unduly disturbing noise
could you know what he could have been
someone that so when I think about [ __ ]
like I'll be looking at someone but I'm
not really looking at someone like like
I'm just thinking but I well like I'll
be looking at Joe but I'm really
thinking so I could have just been in
deep thoughts and then I fart and then I
come to and I'm like oh [ __ ] there's a
cop what have you fart I hope that Jill
I hope that Gio blinks machine farts -
she's like I think I do I think does
that every time you can just tell
whenever Geoforce from across the room
already staring at you
Gio's in a meeting and she's like yeah
so I think this is a very interesting
proposal
and yeah we can get it let's get wheels
up on this Jesus part no it's either
blink or open up wider I do flex one of
my light cheeks Allah do you live the
budget depends on which side you lift
yeah that's what cheek goes up I'm not
that uh self aware and I push it as hard
as I can
why would you want to do that I just I
don't know I [ __ ] yourself huh
you want to feel this all the [ __ ] I just
so like satisfying it all just comes out
of one now you're [ __ ] begging and
get some [ __ ] on you sometimes I'm like
a [ __ ] scared spider monkey when I
fart usually Nicki's asleep and it's me
alone what is that you never seen the
scared spider monkey before oh I nailed
it trust me and that's what I'm farting
nobody's just overwhelming to my body
cuz I've been holding it in PI all day
you know I escaped to the bathroom no
I'm a good boy no women's parts and gets
stuck in under [ __ ] in their [ __ ] lips
yeah what are you talking it goes like
that like it ripples blue yeah you said
it like that I was like oh that's so
sweet so let's take this and be like
this no trouble like this that's pretty
hot so your butt's here right yeah no I
get it
jazz hands and then you have to lift one
leg too if you think I don't know this
guy's fart on that one balls all the
time they didn't laugh they know what
the word tracking you know before the
balls and the times we have to adjust to
get the Arabs
we're the same after all think about it
the next time you're sucking on a pair
of balls not that fun is it no cuz you
don't know like it's like like in the
paint area
how's it your note by your balls I think
the ball cup don't know how you're
sitting you don't know how you're
sitting so sometimes you just part into
a cavity and then you're like oh it's
there and then later you lift up and
then it your balls like peel from your
acid or a lake or something and then
you're like oh there's a smell it seems
like you're Paul temporarily for a
couple of seconds you it's like a
parachute oh yeah they're on the
International Space Station doing one of
my favorite things to do is fart in the
bath who sees what you are that feeling
of like what have you actually short in
the back
[ __ ] it what's the back of the pool dude
this before but that happened to me when
I was in the shower once what in the
shower okay so I was sick I was sick oh
this is recent she wasn't experimenting
she was sick no I was sick I literally
had like food poisoning or something and
then it was when we're all in Vegas
remember that time in Vegas when I was
like [ __ ] yeah where was that was this
singing we invited everyone but someone
was sad I get it
I didn't feel like I wanted to go there
and Gamble I was I had food poisoning
I have things with people man I get it I
don't know people I thank you but you'd
come next time
oh yeah cuz I know you know but if I
yeah but you yes you had food poisoning
and then you know it like it was so bad
that when we had just gotten to the
hotel I ran to the bathroom to go throw
up like that was like the worst ever I
was like green what did ye yeah oh it
was scallops from sugar
but it was delivery temperature the town
itíd the whole room makes sense
scallops are already dangerous anyway is
they getting it delivered it's like oh
boy times they're pretty good about it
cuz one time we ordered and then we did
the accidental thing where we were
supposed to get it delivered but we
clicked pick it up and then we were
waiting for and they're like hey it's
been longer than 10 20 minutes or
whatever wept to throw it away so
they're good about that
that's why but yes I was in the shower
[ __ ] up this was the hotel shower
right even on property
oh good honestly did it feel good just
kind of did did you poke what is the
legs up on the bathtub no would you tell
Katie yeah I did I was like a straight
up took a [ __ ] did you point your butt
through the hole did you squat it in the
[ __ ] caca
did you step it into the drain it was
like clumpy no no I mean it was straight
up diarrhea [ __ ] did you try to take a
[ __ ] on the soap holder what okay some
bubbles oh they go [ __ ] it they gonna
throw up again I'm like oh no no no it's
coming the other way must be a fart
squatty right over the drain I'm like
this is happening
who's your hotel curtains or sliding
door no it was a dork you realize what
you're doing the sexual fantasies of
thousands of this is the woman who
judges my class shower in a hotel and I
cleaned it after
you shampooed on the cat to [ __ ]
scrub the shagging woman gum and then
you wake it downstairs and touched a
bunch of dice thanks for that didn't
wash my hands
well I'm sure you did but I calls that
are hiding in between your bigger breaks
I scrub the [ __ ] under my nails to them
like this is [ __ ] this I was so
disgusted with myself that's how I felt
this good why it's not your will [ __ ]
yeah I just felt so like I think you
should do it again when it's not in the
toilet it feels very nasty what I don't
like about that though is when it's a
hot shower the steam poop steam it was
it was that yeah it's like you breathe
that edit [ __ ] I wish I was one of those
people who like my own smell cuz then
I'd be like oh but it might be a party
there's a lot of people like that yeah I
said it around Casey he's like something
that happened in Vegas and you wanted to
stay in Vegas nice but it didn't it's
here in Singapore now few years for me
to confess it take some big pair of
balls to do that good for a big big
[ __ ] real big personal thank you for
which parts to still get trapped in by
the way even bigger for what was this
about it was about the guy who got
ticketed for oh yeah we're still on
trying Vienna exactly and so they said
that if this fine is not paid within
five days he will face five days in jail
so this this I'll go to jail this whole
thing got posted on on reddit and then
people were like what those luckily
that's not cool you can't fart around
him you have a right to break when
wherever you want but then people were
then the cops were like no no no no you
did this intentionally but how would you
know because of what I had they
described it oh yeah it's okay the goal
over here
rips it yeah I mean that's a funny way
to insult someone it's just hey
right you pal you look like a fool doing
that and thought to me shoes please
this is what they said the fine was a
culmination of a prolonged unruly and
disrespectful behavior of the accused
who constantly disrupted a police
intervention the intense intestinal wind
was as he not the beginning but the end
of a longer lasting incident the tip of
the behavioural iceberg so to speak he
ended it with a fart I hope it was worth
it your honor
I know the whole time even in jail do
you have anything to say I will put you
in contact man put me that be cool to
have that power you could just say [ __ ]
some people can do that and it sounds
like a balloon like people that like
finger people you know [ __ ] thought then
he meant like a fart would come out if
you pull someone's finger I didn't know
it was a joke but
[Music]